public hearing on Senate Bill 203 and I
call the sponsor represent senator avard
who will give us a pink card when after
he's finished
thank you madam chair and committee
members for the record I'm Senator Kevin
abart I represent District 12.
we
three Wars in Nashua Mason Rindge Hollis
Brookline New Hope switch and Greenville
all right so we've got the uh got the
sound how you doing
all right uh so as the prime sponsor of
this bill this bill basically changes
the membership of the board of
Manufacturing Housing it increases the
board of jurisdiction to matters under
RSA 301a
on a consumer Cooperative Association
and it gives the tenant association
standings with the board of
Manufacturing Housing
uh again this bill basically changes the
membership of the board of Manufacturing
Housing and includes membership of
Resident owned communities it also
increases the board of jurisdiction like
I just read to add dispute resolution
process for both the investor owned and
Resident owned Manufacturing Housing
communities
this increases uh the increase in
jurisdiction will not be a burden to the
board as their website lists only three
cases since 2019.
uh which is the most recent information
that's been given
it's basically a common sense approach
that this bill for brides it is used to
uh use that existing board to hear
disputes from both investor owned and
Resident owned Community residents
resident owned communities represent
one-third of all the Manufacturing
Housing parks in the state
more resident Representatives on the
board can identify and deal with issues
specific to resident resident owned
communities
and expanding the membership of the
board allows for a broader range of
housing expertise issues and choices
a recreated board will be less focused
on the business of owning the
Manufacturing Housing parks and more on
solving the problems of mostly low to
moderate income homeowners
the Senate Amendment reduces the number
of members on the board from 11 to 5 and
added the process for oplc to field
complaints and if there are any uh
technical things I I have some people
here that would like to to speak on it
we run into that a lot but uh
that's my testimony Madam chair
committee thank you Senator I have a
a couple of of questions that you should
be able to answer the first question is
that the governor repealed this board in
House Bill 2 and there was no opposition
in the house to leaving it in-house to
leaving that repeal in House Bill too so
uh you are essentially recreating the
board is it is that your understanding
okay some things are just out of our
control
indeed okay so you haven't coordinated
this with the governor not yet not yet
okay
okay uh the other question is you appear
to have stuck it into the
office of professional licensure and
certification this strikes me as
something that would be more appropriate
appropriately in the Department of
Justice the consumer complaints division
uh is there any reason you didn't do
that or have you considered doing that
I'd not consider that but I'm open to
suggestions all right thank you does
anyone else on the committee have a
question
all right thank you very much thank you
madam chair thank you committee members
this has been fun
we hope to see you more often
all right I'd like to call Chris Nyland
good morning seniles
um my name is Kristen Island I live at
eight Spring Drive in Derry New
Hampshire at um uh mobile home park
called Centennial Estates it's roc's
100th
Mobile Home Park
I've been there for nine years
um back in 2019 we all got a letter
saying the entire Board of directives
was resigning effective immediately
and they had given us a list of things
that you know we could that we could try
and take on our own
so I went on a campaign and tried to get
four other neighbors together and put
together an annual meeting
and I did so and I was voted elected
president
uh we had reached the Quorum and um
so
on June 1st 2019 I became elected the
president of Centennial Estates
over the next 58 days
I was sent sexually explicit messages
from teenage girls being raped to
bedroom sex scenes with animals to gay
bashing
and it just goes on and on the treasurer
had never paid taxes she had owed over
nine thousand dollars on her home at the
time
it's ruined my life
since then
once I found out about the lawsuit and
how Roc had been swindling money out of
our accounts to pay for a lawsuit
it's it's it's a bad situation but
anyway they they contacted Hodges one
time and and stated that I had resigned
my position
and nobody's really ever talked to me
since
now it's been four years we haven't had
any monthly meetings
we haven't had any annual meetings
we've had no elections
right now we have a husband and a wife
pretending to be board members who have
locked themselves up in their houses and
are not posting any agendas and nobody
knows anything about what's going on
our water is contaminated with peepas
we're being injected with chlorine in
our water we have septic in our water
the park looks like a third world
country like something you'd see in
Mexico
but meanwhile we don't even own a
lawnmower we have 24 acres and we have
zero assets and every time I call Kelly
or Tara at the Community Loan Fund
my complaints go unanswered over 50
emails since 2019 begging them to get
involved and take control of the park
and or put me back in or do something
everything goes unanswered well
so
this year when they were trying to get
out of having another annual meeting I
started calling and they had one of my
neighbors come up and I got punched in
the mouth and all my teeth knocked out
because I was asking
demanding that Roc have a meeting so
when I see this and I see that you want
to that they want to have two positions
on a board of directors I say nope I I'm
thinking sb64 you need to sit and listen
to the residents of the resident owned
communities and we need to come up with
a serious plan to be able to hold
Community Loan Fund accountable for
their actions because right now we're
missing over four hundred thousand
dollars in our Park funds from a line of
credit they've given unelected members
to spend
I've called the oplc I called the
attorney general I send the emails
nobody has control of anything
and this is a 58 24 acre
58 unit Mobile Home Park
and nobody has control oversight there's
nobody to call there's nobody to file a
complaint to
I vote no on this Bill thank you
funny uh alsoof
Bonnie
I'm sorry I can't read your family name
is it okay if I sit with her sure
please and please introduce yourself
please oh yes my name is Bonnie garies
Bonnie what garies g-a-w-r-y-s good
morning Madam chairman
my name is Bonnie garies and I am a
resident of Bayview Community co-op in
Allenstown and I'm here today to testify
in our position of SB 203
Fairview as well as many other co-ops
are in dire need of a dispute resolution
program but this bill is not the answer
I have been working with many other
residential communities over the past
three years to address the issues and
have been fought by the New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund every step of the
way until now
Bayview became a co-op three years ago
and for those three years our park has
been led by three different sets of
boards of directors and now our park is
in shambles we have experienced board
members not following our bylaws not
applying the rules consistently to
everyone
that is a resident in the park this is
not unique to our community as a New
Hampshire Community Health fund has
testified in the past
SB 203 was filed by the New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund in response to SB 64
that creates a study committee on
Resident owned manufactured housing
parts
despite excuse me disputes and oversight
of Resident owned manufactured housing
Parks the goal was to try to develop a
dispute resolution program at no expense
to the state and to determine if there
are appropriate oversights of Resident
owned communities
excuse me this is where he dared me and
I'm sorry
SB 203 gets the membership of the board
of manufactured housing and places the
burden of resolving these conflicts on
the state
it allows the New Hampshire Community
Home Loan Fund the lender to nominate a
resident to the board removes the member
of the New Hampshire buyer Association
and replaces it with a housing advocacy
member and it removes legislative
participation on the board this does not
create a balanced board
these are not pro-resident changes these
are pro-new Hampshire Community Loan
Fund changes these changes will only
result in protecting the New Hampshire
Community Home Loan Fund and their
attempts to smother residents voices and
complaints which allows them to continue
to lure residents into purchasing their
Parks which directly benefits The Loan
Fund
please understand
that not all residents in Resident or
communities wanted to purchase their
parks
it does not take a majority of residents
to vote to purchase a park
isn't that odd
for example our park in our park we have
287 units
and only 68 people voted to purchase the
park
I think if you had a larger base of
support to purchase the park we wouldn't
have these problems not to mention the
scare tactics Scare Tactics that
Community Home Loan Fund used to present
to us to purchase the pack or Finance
the park from them I respectfully ask
the committee to vote to kill this bill
and support an alternative bill that
will bring the stakeholders together to
resolve these issues without burdening
the state
I hope my testimony will not put a
larger Target on my back by the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund as they
have done
they have done enough damage to my
character and assassinated my character
my character
to the point where I am now looking into
legal counsel I will be happy to answer
any questions for you and thank you for
your time
thank you Miss virus thank you thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
okay I don't I don't see any I think
you've
thank you very much thank you and you
and you madam Louise right out
okay
my name is Louise Rideout I'm a resident
of the Bayview Crossing Cooperative in
Allenstown New Hampshire I've been there
since before
we became a co-op
and I have I'll read what I wrote
I am voicing my opposition con concerns
to Senate Bill 203 because of two
important factors first Senate Bill 203
will be a burden to New Hampshire
taxpayers funding will be needed for the
manufactured housing board to exist I am
a taxpayer
as I am a homeowner so at a very
difficult time in this economic
environment we should not be a burden
rocks are already stigmatized as
recipients of the generosity of
donations and funding as we are labeled
as low to moderate income homeowners and
please remember the term homeowners
homeowners and taxpayers but we really
know that is not all truthful I question
the involvement of New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund for this bill
it is clearly a conflict of interest for
lenders of Resident and owned
communities to be participants on any
type of resolution board I don't see how
you can see it any other way than the
conflict of interest
because when we have issues
with them as I will explain to you what
happened just this week to me
there's no resolution for us
and we're targeted in my personal
experience with New Hampshire Community
Loan Fund I realized that they might not
be able to be unbiased
I have an email which I will show you
that I sent to Chris classby regarding
our forensic audit because our Co-op is
currently for a year and a half been in
a non-monetary default
issued by Community Loan Fund and right
now I'm afraid to say anything because
I'm afraid that
the powers that be with Community Loan
Fund will turn around and raise our
interest rate
so that that is something they could do
and I don't want to be held responsible
for so hopefully that is something they
won't do
now I I sent it about to Chris classby
and I also forwarded it to Steve
Saltzman who is the CEO Tara Reardon who
is the vice president in Kelly
ciccarelli who is our technical advisor
I received an unintended email from
Steve Salzman which I brought with me
Senate and I I have to show you this
because I sent it to Chris when I
forwarded Steve sauceman didn't realize
he was sending back to me let's get
unified on the type of response
regarding Miss Rideout we'll use
whatever we write
and then he tried to retract
so if you want to use you put a bill
through that they have more power than
they already have over us it was going
to hurt us a lot and I don't think
that's fair
Senator avod mentions that there needs
to be modernization of the manufactured
housing board but I don't understand
what he's referring to I did leave a
message but he never reached out to me
to get back in touch Senate Bill 64
addresses the needs for all manufactured
home parks in an unbiased manner that
would allow members homeowners to go
forward without fear of retaliation
we deserve to have a board that would be
honest and trustworthy without the deck
being stacked to accommodate New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund having
more unnecessary control of Our Lives
the solution is in my eyes is to stop
this bill and give more effort to the
success of Senate bill 64.
thank you for listening Louise Rhino
thank you and I would like you to share
this with you
thank you
are there any questions representative a
bears
good morning thank you for being here to
share your experience with us so
as I'm reviewing the bill the members on
the board are moving from nine members
to five members and
from what you're saying what would your
choice be for who would sit on the board
if they're not appointed who who would
sit on the board
I would I would think it would be
somebody that is absolutely unbiased and
non-partial
you know somebody that
maybe a retired person that has a lot of
experience and negotiations
nobody involved in that lending process
because lenders
uh frightening you know what I'm saying
they're like they control you they tell
you what you can and can't do so and not
people that are hand-picked you know
maybe people can put their requests and
you know people at the parks can ask to
be in and maybe they can be reviewed
like I don't know what you might think
that would be a good idea like a say a
retired um legislator a retired judge
somebody that has experience in the
negotiations with
any type of dispute but to have have our
lender
A lender be
part of this is we're afraid to even you
know have any contact with these people
please don't do that to us thank you
yes please go on I'm I'm sorry guards
again I do I I have to mirror but
what she's saying
because the two of us have been
retaliated against since we've started
being very vocal in fact last year a
member from the New Hampshire Community
Home Loan Fund went to our board and
told our board to contact the parks
attorney to have Louisa Knight evicted
from the park because we were too vocal
so having people that Community Home
Loan Fund pick to sit on these boards
that's not going to help us at all
it's not I mean
right now I have about a hundred parks
in the state that I that call me with
their problems because they are not
getting any response and no help from
Community Home Loan Fund I myself have
filed six complaints in the past seven
months
and I have not heard one word
we are having a forensic audit because
our park is missing a half a million
dollars
and
because New Hampshire Community Loan
Fund was not doing the fiduciary duty
that we were paying the form I correct
every month consequently
we're missing a half million dollars and
nobody wanted to do anything about it
until Louise and I finally contacted the
um who do we call the attorney general
for the charitable organization and he
has requested a forensic audit be done
which I don't think that we being bfu
Community Co-op should have to pay for
because it's not our fault our money's
missing the fault lies on Community Home
Loan Fund who didn't do their job but
again people are too afraid to speak up
they are scared to death because of
retaliation especially when they see
what's happened to Louise and I I'm
being honest I'm fearful today
so I don't know what's coming down the
pike I've had my car damaged at my home
it's it's scary but like I said but they
have my character to have my character
no that's not good because I'm vocal
because I'm trying to stick up for
members in these co-ops give us some
good good foundation for us we all
deserve it we pay taxes we deserve it
you deserve unbiased help these people
need to be heard they they need we need
to be heard
thank you madam thank you very much
are there any representative gerhardt
thank you madam chair
so the the main concerns that you guys
want fixed
have to do with the financial aspects of
just so basically people coming in
giving bags of money to people it
disappears now you guys are on the hook
board is that the main thrust of what's
going on my point being is why can't
this be done at the local Town level at
some point or do the town you know what
I'm saying the local entities
the town is not involved
for fraud for you know what I'm saying I
just has to go Statewide I'm just I'm
totally ignoring
many many agencies I was a terrible
employee for 18 years so I have called
many places and it's hard for people to
want to even get involved because the
the power of that Community Long John
has in this state dominates the whole
thing yes I think they're not regulated
by anybody
okay are there any other questions
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned that a
non-monetary default status can you
explain that
when we are paying our loans
so I'm sorry we are paying our loans but
there are some aspects of our loan
documents that require us to have
certain things done properly like having
the boards be filled five members of the
boards to be able to have the budgets
done all the paperwork has to be filed
in a timely manner and we have to have a
good relationship with our management
company and our management company is
owned by
um
Steve Dupree
FoxFi management and I was personally
told that he took on these co-ops as a
favor
to the vice presidents of Community Loan
fund's husband so you know we have we
have a lot to deal with thank you thank
you for your answer
other questions thank you very much for
your testimony thank you for listening
thank you
should I pass this over here please we
would very much appreciate it
Tara Reardon
good morning Madam chair and members of
the House Edna committee
um
I previously had passed out my testimony
to you a little chart that shows you the
configuration of the members of the
board
before SB 203 and afterwards and then a
printout from the website for the
dispute resolution board which I think
is really helpful and um
is a gives you some idea of the dispute
resolution process in place now
my name is Tara Reardon I'm here in
support of Senate Bill 203 and I work
for the New Hampshire Community Loan
Fund I passed you out the annual report
it has a lot about us in there so I
won't rehash any of that
it is a 40 year old Community Loan Fund
that serves the citizens of the State of
New Hampshire and it provides access to
Capital money loans that Banks won't
give people because they won't qualify
for them and that's our mission to serve
that group of people
the oldest and largest program of the
New Hampshire Community Loan Fund is
Rock NH and that stands for Resident
owned communities New Hampshire
and it is how the Loan Fund got started
when residents land under their home
comes up for sale this legislature very
forward thinking back in the 90s not
only made their manufactured housing
real property but it also gave them an
opportunity to purchase that land under
their homes and that was the beginning
of the rock program
when you own a home on on rented land
that's a very unstable kind of Housing
and having a resident owned community
stabilizes that forever in perpetuity
these rocks are organized as not for
profit consumer cooperatives under RSA
under RSA
301a and when they if if they ever chose
that no one has ever chosen to sell
their Community they can't profit from
that sale that would go to another like
kind affordable housing use
so thanks to you and the people who have
sat in the seats before you there's 9
000 households in the state of New
Hampshire and 145 different communities
that are rocks that don't have to worry
about having to ever have the land sold
and them moving their home or walking
away from the biggest asset that they
will ever own so it is a really smart
Common Sense affordable housing solution
that this legislature created and it has
now spread across the United States
where there's over 300 rocks in the
United States right now
foreign
when we're working with rocks is that
them owning their home and paying for
the land rent their taxes and insurance
is cheaper than the two-bedroom rental
in the same area so a really important
source of affordable housing in all of
your communities you probably all have a
rock in your community I'd love to
answer your questions at any time if
you're interested in visiting them and
meeting the hard-working people that
work there
um so the the makeup of these
communities is low-income people we do
because of our mission have to serve
low-income folks and we do income
surveys routinely 75 percent of the
people that live in these communities
are at or below 80 percent of area
median income 10 of them are veterans 28
of them are disability have a disability
two Rock communities that we work with
the town clerk lives there there's a
community in Loudoun that a retired
police officer is actually the president
of that Co-op right now teachers County
Nursing Home employees and more
so of those 145 rocks in New Hampshire
those 9 000 households most of them run
very very smoothly but there's people
involved and people don't always get
along with each other and prior boards
don't necessarily think the next board
is doing it the way they are so disputes
arise about fences about parking about
dogs about meeting notices about their
finances and sometimes a board believes
it has more power than it does and
somebody needs to resolve that dispute
the manufactured housing board has
existed since the 1990s and in the early
years it heard between 12 and 20 cases a
year and those cases are almost evenly
divided between folks in Resident owned
communities and folks in investor own
communities which is an important Point
here the study committee that has been
alluded to before
is about the oversight of rocks this
isn't just about rocks in the senate
committee a woman very passionately
testified that routinely her water got
turned off when she was getting ready
for work or or trying to go out and she
didn't dare say a thing to her landlord
about that for fear of she would be
retaliated against so there's disputes
in all kinds of these communities and
since 2019 the I checked with the oplc
no cases have been heard since that time
could be coveted related maybe not but
we've had three residents call us just
this year that said when they called the
manufactured housing board they were
referred the park Owners Association the
park Owners Association has very
different goals than the resident owned
communities you know
and just yesterday Senator avard got an
email from someone who had an issue
called the manufactured housing board
was referred to 603 legal aid they they
didn't even field the complaint for him
I've spoken with Lindsay about the
revamping Lindsay Courtney excuse me
about the revamping about HB 655 what
would be included in that in this bill
and that is why Senator Carson and
Senator Perkins Coker in the Senate
re-re-did this the uh the composition of
the manufactured housing board to make
it a smaller board and left in the added
jurisdiction that we had contemplated of
uh regular meetings meeting notices what
happens when a residence being expelled
from the community
so when the manufactured housing board
was formed there were only 30 rocks in
the state of New Hampshire and there's
145 now we believe the composition of
the board two Park owners two residents
one from an investor owned Community one
from Iraq and someone from housing
action New Hampshire somebody
experienced in low-income housing and
the issues that come with that is a fair
representation in a me likely to be a
better board and a fairer complaint
board for that
so the jurisdiction goes beyond just the
reasonableness of the rules in the Park
which is what the jurisdiction is now as
you can see from the handout the board
already has a really well done
um website and we believe that this is a
forum where a resident or a park owner
can represent themselves we're not going
to add to the superior court docket or
have somebody incur legal fees in order
to solve this dispute these are
low-income folks and it is a path that
they can afford to do on their own
I'd like the committee to find this bill
ought to pass we're happy to work with
the committee
to answer any questions and clarify
anything that you've already heard and I
will say that money is often
um an issue in these communities as
you've heard from people who have
testified before bear view Cooperative
is undergoing a forensic Financial
author uh audit right now because
there's money missing and the money is
missing because a board member signed a
letter uh to Merrimack County Savings
Bank asking to have some of those funds
diverted and that's what's being
investigated and that forensic audit
and that may lead to charges there we've
had embezzlement in communities before
where folks have ended up in jail
um we have offered the uh had a
conversation with the Department of
Justice about whether this is better
situated there and they would prefer not
to have that as part of their
jurisdiction their self-governing boards
we don't get a vote in anything we do
enforce our loan covenants and documents
they have to have clean audits clean
Financial records most of these groups
have Professional Property Management
that does that for them unless somebody
is intentionally diverting funds which
is exactly what's happened at Bear view
here but um where the source of the down
payment money that allows these groups
to buy their communities and of course
we have loan covenants that go with that
there
um I will be happy to answer any
questions or clarify or work with a
subcommittee that comes after this bill
but I think a dispute resolution
forum is in order wherever it sits in
the state of New Hampshire
thank you uh representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
did you say that the homeowners
um are not allowed to sell to recognize
any profit from the investment in their
property
homeowners are always free to sell their
homes on the open real estate market
list it they own their homes
individually the community is owned as a
consumer Cooperative not in an
individual's name but in the case of
bear view bear view cooperative
if that property is sold because they
are organized as a not-for-profit they
do not benefit from the sale of that
they'd get their membership fees back
which are someplace between 25 and 500
depending on where you are but the money
would go to the charitable trust
Division and go to another like kind
affordable housing effort
follow-up follow-up
I was very active I was head of Habitat
for Humanity in New Hampshire back when
all of this was put in place
and I remember the the um vilification
and criticism that Habitat for Humanity
homeowners would be allowed to sell
their property and and recognize a
profit and that this this program was
intended to keep low-income housing for
low-income people how many times have
you pointed out in your testimony that
these are very poor people
um we that is part of our mission at the
Community Loan Fund my question was how
many times did you point out and I don't
believe that's a question she can
actually answer thank you
uh-huh representative shewitt and then a
bear
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question you mentioned
um that somebody needs to
um
resolve disputes that arise and I'm I'm
hearing that it sounds as though these
folks have moved into these communities
and then suddenly the ownership changes
and they've gotten involved in a
leadership position that they hadn't
really signed on for when they purchased
their location in the Parks
uh it appears that the current board has
been unable to resolve a lot of disputes
from what we're hearing
can you tell us why you think this new
board would be better at that or if it
would be
uh so the manufactured housing board at
the state level hasn't heard any
disputes there is a board that governs
each resident owned Community that's
elected by the members themselves people
who have testified have been members of
their boards
oftentimes it's rules interpretation
sometimes it's the failure to hold
meetings which is something that a
member could bring to the manufactured
housing board if a meeting hasn't been
held in accordance with their bylaws and
then the board is called on the carpet
to ask why there hasn't been a meeting
or why the meetings haven't been
properly noticed so a member can go to
that I think just the very existence of
a functioning board that does make those
kinds of decisions
May improve the behavior
of sub-members because they know that
there is a dispute resolution for
residents that aren't being heard in
their own communities
thank you personally bear
thank you madam chair
why now why
change the
board from nine to five I notice on the
website that
it's required to have two members from
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives which remain vacant at
this time so there's no representation
in that manner why now
we filed uh SB 203 before we saw hb2 to
see that it was going to be eliminated
because we thought the function could be
better oplc told us that the the
legislators appointed never showed up
they didn't they weren't interested they
didn't actually go to it oplc's
streamlining of the number of boards
that they have also included the size of
some boards making them a little weirdly
um
a higher level to reach a quorum so that
made sense and for us it also made sense
that now that there's about 450
manufactured housing parks in the state
of New Hampshire
one-third of those are now resident
owned when this board was formed that
was Far different there were only 30 at
that time it was a fairly new phenomenon
so the need for dispute resolution has
always existed the makeup of the board
is just changing with the character of
manufactured housing in the state of New
Hampshire and I never could have
anticipated that the this was the year
that the governor would decide that oplc
needed to be overhauled that's just a
coincidence that that happened
okay I'd like to comment that the oplc
has not been involved in this board as
far as I know it's not attached to them
at the moment
it lives at oplc some staffer from oplc
answers the phone when uh when we go
lovely uh
I'm very concerned about your
um
about the stories we hear about
retaliation and that's something that
I've heard from a number of constituents
because I do have a number of both
resident owned and non-resident owned
um homes in my in my district
and so I'm very concerned about the
stories of retaliation
and in fact one one park in Epsom was uh
considering becoming resident down and
they couldn't and due to uh flood
flooding issues they were not eligible
and so I had a lot of people concerned
about how the Community
Loan Fund was organized and how it was
attempting to
create a resident owned community
and which have not been answered yep we
worked with that community in Epsom
unfortunately
a lot of homes were not just in the
flood flood plain they were in the flood
way
we were also working with cdbg and
another lender we couldn't finance that
whole thing it was a huge purchase price
and all of those lenders declined to
finance anything that had people
actually living in a flood way at that
time
and and I agree with retaliation in
Parks people this job would be very easy
but for the people who have a need to
not treat their neighbors as kindly as
they should and I I think it's further
need for dispute resolution uh some kind
of forum where people know that they'll
thank you other questions representative
Billa
thank you ma'am yeah in the uh procedure
for filing a complaint could you explain
what that entails how someone files a
complaint and what the what the
resolution is uh uh certainly executive
director Courtney might be better suited
to answer this but my understanding is
there's an online Complaint Form that is
filled out sent to
the board of manufactured housing
they'll make a decision whether they
have jurisdiction over that or not and
then if so
um and the chair actually of the board
of manufactured housings here too he
could let you know how that works from
there uh in the in a hearing schedule
follow-up
there's I guess a 25 fee for filing a
complaint but it can be waived can you
explain what the conditions are for
waving I don't know anything about what
the conditions for the waiver I'm sorry
thank you
represent goalie
thank you madam chair
I saw a director Courtney leave but I
have a question maybe you can answer
um
how did
the office of professional licensure and
certification become involved in the
ones to field all the complaints
this is not a licensing this has nothing
to do with licensing
who's going to pay for the costs because
all the costs to run oplc come from
licensees why is this in here
we didn't change where the board sat and
it has been there as long as I've been
familiar with the board we are totally
open to it sitting at the Department of
Justice if that's a better forum for it
um
yeah yes thank you you're correct about
the funding though that's
seems inappropriate
or any other questions representative
O'Brien
thank you madam chair and uh Miss
Redding good to see you again nice to
see you uh thank you for taking my
question I'm very concerned
okay we heard from some of the people
that testified and they actually fear
and I'll take it as legitimate concerns
what do you see as the fix to some of
that that may be in this particular bill
can you upon on that a little bit
um bear view Cooperative in the
Allenstown has had a series of boards
um where one board is critical of what
the other board did and does its best to
bring that to the Forefront
I don't know how the neighbors act when
where we are there for a board meeting
we're not on site they have a
professional property manager that does
their books we handle board meetings
um
there will be inquiries from residents
from time to time about a board matter
our policy and this is what our CEO
Saltzman was referring to is that when
we give information out we give the same
information to everybody if somebody
asks a question we'll respond to the
board and that person and then everybody
is working from the same information
because there are some residents who
love to do the gotcha moment that they
told me this therefore I know something
that you don't know and we try to avoid
that
thank you
representative bear thank you madam
chair just one last question
do these people have any coaching for
running a board knowing how to put
notice out anything like that the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund Works uh
with about 90 to 100 of these boards
there's several that have paid their
loans off and don't have any interaction
with us anymore and we have on a yearly
basis provide 20 000 hours of technical
assistance so in your first year prior
to buying and in your first year we're
at every board meeting we help with
every agenda all of that and then as um
as co-ops become more and more
independent we're able to just check in
with them before and after meetings to
make sure they know what's going on
we also help them get funding for
infrastructure projects that they need
to do and all kinds of ongoing trainings
that they can take advantage of by Zoom
we have 20 people at traditionally on a
weeknight at a training about
infrastructure or board management or
things like that
any other questions for Mr
thank you very much
thank you manager
this I think will be going to
subcommittee
uh representative shuitt if you think
you can take this on
do you think our subcommittee's got to
handle this
oh okay thank you we'll uh we'll add it
to the burden Mark Tay
good morning Madam chair members uh my
name is Mark Tay
and I am an attorney I'm speaking in
opposition to Senate Bill 203. I've
served on a state board of manufactured
housing continuously since 2004.
and I'm its chair uh since 2007.
um I'm one of the two nominees to the
board from the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association I do
have testimony
um if I may
and now that I passed out my written
testimony part of it was geared towards
the former uh Senate Bill 203 not the
amendment the former bill called for a
membership of 11 increased from nine uh
the current bill before you drops that
membership to five the same concerns
hold though we have a proposed two
members from industry two members who
are residents and then one member from
this
um
manufactured how or the housing action
committee who I heard of Ms Raiden
testify that that's a low-income expert
so essentially the Optics of this newly
constituted board suggests that that one
member will be deciding all future cases
coming before the board
um so I you know I say that because
um
takes a while for a board to get some
cohesion and in the past when we did
have our Representative members our
public member and our member of the bar
uh and as I said I'm the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association
appointee we do have another member of
the bar so the so-called bias members if
you want to use that label the two
industry the two
um
a residents are outweighed by the number
of
um uh people who really don't have a
bias who bring a um an independent
opinion to the board and that's really
helped the board Through The Years
um
this uh Bill also wants to substantially
propose to substantially increase the
jurisdiction of the board of
manufactured housing and fundamentally
change and we're a boy that hears rules
disputes our jurisdiction is clearly
laid out and now
um the board would be asked to resolve a
complex
corporate issues essentially these are
all governance issues that the board
really isn't equipped to handle and also
I should point out the board can't
doesn't have Equity Powers we're an
executive board we're not a Judicial
board although we're quasi-judicial but
we can't order
uh Cooperative to hold a meeting so I
don't know what the point of having to
come to us is but that's what this board
uh Bill suggests
um
I just wanted to address some of the
history of our board uh it was formed in
and at the beginning I think it served a
really important Purpose with respect to
park rules disputes uh it we did provide
a forum to fairly resolve rules issues
and we were pretty active over the last
maybe 20 years or so
of resolving these violation complaints
from tenants in both cooperative and
privately owned manufactured housing
community it was also an opportunity for
members of the board to freely exchange
views with each other
members of industry and residence
members of the then existing tenants
association called Moda who served on
the board had an opportunity to come
together with legislative members to
talk about the issues
those having to do with the case at hand
and other matters just affecting the
industry
that's changed quite a bit over the last
five years or so
um
at our last meeting on March 3rd we had
two members in attendance including
myself
um
I think with this proposal with five
members you're going to have some real
Quorum issues going down the line you're
just not going to get anything done
but we haven't really been
um
you know I've been on the front lines
for a long time with this and I'm
speaking not
um
I don't know if I can touch this uh not
from
uh position of the board itself because
we don't have a quorum we haven't taken
a position as a board on this bill so
I'm seeking just for myself and my own
opinion
um
our complaints have fallen off
dramatically in the last five years as
Miss Reardon testified to part of this
is I think
um
we have a better educated class of Park
owners they know what their obligations
are they know what they can do and what
what they can't do
um judges are more aware of the issues
we have mediation now that's a step in
the court process
and residents are more aware of their
rights and obligations
um
of the three cases that we had
one of them
was dismissed
because
the complainant had previously gone to
court and lost
so you know we're not a board that
overrules a Judicial decision so we had
to decline
that case
um
there's one case pending now
and we've subsequently learned that that
person decided that while her complaint
was pending she went to small claims
court on the same issues and lost
so we just haven't gotten together to
dismiss it because as I say we don't we
don't overturn uh judicial decisions and
we don't have that Authority uh to do
that
um
and I I wanted to uh just mention
um Moda that was the tenants Association
and that hadn't been in operation since
2011.
um I think it's been recently revived
only a couple of apart from someone in
Moda yeah we'll be talking about it yeah
they revived a couple of weeks ago so
maybe there's a need now
um
I'm afraid that while the board has
served an important historical role uh
it served its purpose
um the suggestion that it should be
um revived by packing it with
um a different membership or reducing to
five the membership
um I don't think that that's
um
it'll work I think it's misdirected uh
breathing life into a more Bond board is
really not the answer here I do suggest
that the answer lies with the Community
Loan Fund to solve a problems endemic
and cooperatively own parks
which is what this bill seeks to have
the board do but instead of putting this
on the board of manufactured housing and
on state resources I think it would be
far more effective for the Loan Fund to
set up and pay for a mediation program
uh in these cooperatively owned
communities
and arrange for that private meeting
similar to what the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association does in
the case of disputes over rent in
privately owned communities
um
they're required by Statute to
advise residents that there is this
mediation program available I don't see
why the Loan Fund can't do that
um and I also believe I heard reference
to Senate Bill 64 which is making its
way through the system to study the
issues that are
that have Arisen in cooperatively owned
communities and I think maybe there will
be some answers to come out of that
thank you for your time okay thank you
representative
yes
excuse me Mr tay but then we do have one
I'm sorry
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question it's me
my question is uh we heard something
about
um
if you're a resident of a park and and
there's a movement to form one of these
rocks I guess you call them that uh
that a minority of the homeowners
can make that decision for a majority
can you speak to that do you know about
that there was some legislation that
passed last year and I have to refresh
myself but in the past yes
um it was the number of people attending
a meeting and that out of that number a
majority and so that was where
um you know a very small majority of the
residents would vote in favor and then
it would happen I think that's like a
sound meeting right who shows up has the
power yeah that's right and I think that
there's been some legislation I don't
know that it fully addresses uh the
issues frankly I I'm not keeping up with
that legislation so I don't know I'm
just generally aware that it was
legislation that changed that was very
helpful thank you very much you're
welcome thank you thank you Mr Tay
representative Olney sorry about that
sorry
is the one that we brought in to talk
about our condominium problems
about 10 years ago
you had retired and you came back
no no that's that's retired me
sorry uh Susan lme on representative
city of Lebanon on and
I wanted to clear up just a couple of
things I've had a number of things
cleared up for me as I've been sitting
here listening on if
you were the Commerce Committee you'd
know quite a lot about this
but I'm not sure why we got this built I
think would be more appropriate in
Commerce but yes go on but
um they this I know something about this
issue though I've been filling in a lot
of recent blanks as I've been listening
because uh the Condominiums and
homeowner associations have the same
problems of on citizens with no help
from outside except for the ones that
are served by rocks on
being able and the ones that go to have
gone to the manufactured housing board
on
being able to figure out how to govern
themselves and run small towns
governments all by themselves with
without anybody to help and I've been
working on that for quite a while on the
reason
that the manufactured housing board
ended up in on
oplc is that they had no place else to
put it that state didn't want to have to
pay for it on 25 even when the 25 was
put in doesn't pay for all the expenses
of it on and it went to
um
it was put into the dedicated funds
category it was put into a group of of
funds on and the rest of them were
yet have to usually pay 25 above the
cost of of their operation to the state
and some of that money went to keep
having that going
on it's
it's served an incredibly important
function and I believe that in one way
it still does because it's website on
has a great deal of information on it
for on members and boards that that go
to it trying to find out okay this
person is saying that I shouldn't be
doing this or I should be doing that and
and there are the results of the
previous cases
and as it was explained to us when we
started the condominium committee on
their
the lawyer was on that board
specifically to on make sure that all
the rulings of the board were put in
language that would be acceptable to the
courts they were filed in the courts and
maybe Mr Tay has a different
interpretation of this than the one that
I we received 10 years ago but on
it's filed in the courts if after six
months no one has appealed the verdict
of the board it gets put into the files
of the manufactured housing board and it
is available on the website for people
to look at and say oh gee I guess
they've they really do have that right
or
they probably don't and if I go to court
to try to dispute it I'm just wasting my
money
so that's on as we understood it at the
time 10 years ago that was why they were
starting to see less cases
because as he said the judges understood
better
what on these bodies are about and had a
a body of rulings behind them which they
will still have even if you get rid of
the manufactured housing board
uh frankly I've been trying and the
people that have come in and out of the
legislature with me I've been trying for
some years to
um
get a
near copy of the manufactured housing
board set up for Condominiums and
homeowner associations
because they're still without this help
but it has been very valuable over the
years and I don't think it could have
been that way without the lawyer who was
the one who held the glue together and
the lawyer is being taken out of this
one so that's just all I wanted to say
thank you thank you for the history any
questions
okay very good
Kim cabins
and I trust after the uh
the hour of testimony we've already
heard you won't need 10 minutes
well
this looked like a very simple build
when I first scheduled it I was I was
wrong
no push the button there you go now
you're on red means girl okay
I'll try to be as brief I'll cut as much
as I can good morning committee members
my name is Kim Capon and I'm here on
behalf of Moda manufactured homeowners
and tenants Association to speak in
favor of this legislation
I personally live in a manufactured home
and I do so because if it's
affordability I also do a lot of
volunteering in my community as well as
around the country in support of
Resident owned Community residents and
their boards
Moda manufactured home antennas
Association was started to support the
homeowners as a place to get relief from
unfair practices of Park owners a year
or so before the onset of covet several
of the board members vacated their
positions and as president has passed
away the associate went silent until
recently when it was resurrected by
several residents and rocks who felt
that too often homeowners are victimized
with no no with no known remedy to them
existing I presently serve as president
and we have a small board and group of
volunteers to bring bring back to life
the advocacy group and hopefully bring
back hope for those in manufactured
housing who aren't aware of where to
turn offering guidance and support to
Residents is helpful but when it comes
apparent that Resident rights are being
violated then folks
then folks were referred to the
manufactured housing board to seek
relief
proposed changes to the appointed
members into the jurisdiction of the
Manufacturing Housing board are
necessary in the interest of fairness to
those who would be subject to those
boards Authority I feel that we need to
talk about eliminating
any doubt about this board's legitimate
legitimacy based upon who might serve on
it and those who will benefit by its
existence it cannot look to be
self-serving it needs to balance and it
needs experience the proposed changes go
a long way towards supporting those
attributes the plight of all
manufactured homeowners is the same in
many ways regardless of ownership rocks
face many of the same unfair practices
that violate rsa's governing
manufactured housing owners be it the
residents boards or investor owners
having a separate government body
regulating rocks not only appears
Prejudice but is a layer of government
that is unnecessary the same rsas that
protect manufactured homeowners and
investor owned Parks protect those in
rocks as well there is an additional
layer of laws that protect the rights
and regulation regulate the governance
of rocks that the manufactured housing
bill could easily have oversight
with fair and equal representation of
Park investor owners resident owners I
believe this would not only be
considered an impartial board but be not
subject to criticism as being well
self-serving this Board needs to only be
fair not only be fair it needs checks
and balances to ensure that it maintains
fairness term limits will help with this
as well I contend that the claims of
there being very few complaints as good
cause for eliminating the board is very
short-sighted that thinking might assume
that because of lack of complaints no
residents are being violated in roughly
500 parks in the state a preserved
self-serving board could be a good
reason there are a few along with a lack
of knowledge of its existence and ease
of submitting a complaint for work
working residents and is another
these are the issues we should be
concerned with I talked to many
residents and Resident leads across the
country as well as in New Hampshire and
there are legitimate concerns that motor
is determined to address and that stats
with residents being aware that there is
hope that unfair practices and lack of a
healthy environment can be addressed and
motives hopeful that the manufactured
housing board is a place we can turn to
to support our evidence at resolving
issues of fairness environment and
affordability
the changes to the makeup of the members
bring bring about balance that is needed
both perspectives being honest
both perspectives being honesty and a
balance in charge and discharging
discipline fairly it's jurisdiction
expansion also prevents another layer of
government that is unnecessary as many
times
there can be a crossover of violations
that can be benefic can be dealt with in
the same visit for the residents there
is good work to be done in the support
of this committee would be greatly
appreciated
thank you for your your time uh you're
giving me this time to speak I'll take
your questions
thank you very much are there questions
don't see any thanks again
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate Bill 203
all right seeing none I will belatedly
close the public hearing and move on to
the hearing on Senate bill 146.
and I will introduce them because my
Senator is not here
okay
thank you very much
proceed
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Peter O'Neill I am the legislative aide
for Senator Howard Pearl unfortunately
he could not be here because he is in
the Senate Edna so I will be introducing
Senate Bill 146 on his behalf uh Senate
Bill 146 is relative to the agricultural
Advisory Board this bill removes certain
requirements for the terms of members of
the Agricultural excuse me agriculture
Advisory Board the bill also requires
public notice of a meeting of The
Advisory board that requires the
commissioner the Department of
Agriculture markets and food to leave
the room if requested to do so by a
member of the board it was also amended
by the Senate unfortunately that's all
that I am at Liberty to say for the bill
and cannot take any questions at this
time
thank you very much will not ask any
questions
uh
commissioner Jasper
good morning Madam chairman members of
the committee I am John Jasper
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food and I am in
full support of Senate Bill 146 which
was put in at my request
um the basics I think have been been
covered
there is a lot of confusion
over what the advisory
board is supposed to do and what it does
which became very evident in my
reconfirmation
hearing I have emailed you all a copy of
a recent history of of the board and
what it actually has been doing since
1979 which frankly isn't much except for
touring farms in every five years making
a recommendation to the governor on who
the commissioner
um
should be I am not actually a member of
the board although until well you'll see
it in there at some point
um
the commissioner did ask act as chair of
the board that was uh Duty was taken
away many decades ago although it took
another 10 or more years before that
actually went into practice
um so
yeah I hope you agree with me that laws
should not be aspirational they should
be functional many of the things that
are in the current duties of the board
turn out to be more aspirational than
realistic and that's why I've requested
all these things be taken out because
they have actually never been done at
least in the last uh 44 years
so
um the real function of the board is
just to make that recommendation to to
the governor that's actually what they
have have done they should be doing more
in my opinion but it's very hard to get
a volunteer group that meets a couple of
times a year to actually do any more
than just check in they'll be meeting in
a couple of weeks and they'll be meeting
with the division heads to get an update
on what's what's going on one of the
things that we've asked to be taken out
is the term limit because it is
extremely difficult to actually get
members to serve on this committee and
get them to show up so when you have a
good member uh probably a good idea to
keep them there
what has been happening although it's
the governor's responsibility to
nominate
to the council it's really been the
commissioner who has been suggesting
that
to the governor and then been moving
forward there now there are some of the
some of the members we're not suggesting
that the membership be changed some of
those seats have been vacant for another
number of while there's supposed to be
fuel dealers that's not really something
that I'm familiar with who to get some
of the wholesalers so those seats are
are vacant but I have made it uh clear
to the to the board that here on out I
am going to expect them to make
recommendations to the governor I find
it to be a bit of a conflict of interest
for the commissioner to actually be
making recommendations to the governor
uh for a board that is supposed to
make recommendations to the commissioner
as it is currently it's pretty much a
hand-picked group by the Commissioner of
Agriculture and so your hand-picked
members are in in fact advising advising
the commissioner I don't like that model
and so that's going to return there I I
hope I want to make you aware of the
fact that there is a conflict
in House Bill 2
with Senate bill 146.
after the confirmation process the
governor put in House Bill 2 or require
requirement that the board go back to
meeting
four times a year as you'll see in the
email I I sent you the attachment that
never happened even when there was a
requirement for them to meet four times
a year and so I don't know what anybody
can do to make the meat four times a
year that's just not realistic they hope
to meet three times a year that's their
plan one time in Concord and then take
their show out on the road if you will
and meet in different counties
however
um
Pages
47 47 48 there's a section that leaves
in all of the aspirational goals and um
and really conflicts with this so I'm
will be asking that the Senate removed
that section I did ask that the house
removed the whole section instead it got
amended and now we have these
conflicting pieces of legislation so
um I'll leave my my remarks there and I
will be glad to answer any questions uh
that I can
Brian has a question thank you madam
chair yes my question is uh on the term
limits I think in modern times we get a
address these issues it is tough to get
volunteers to come in and spend the
required amount of time but at the end
there's a sunset it's the end of year
term and if a member is not adequate
he may not be reinstated
what does your Fail-Safe for an
inadequate member currently if there's
no Sunset of a term
and I don't have the full Statute in
front of me but I believe that it is
three unexcused meetings in a row
okay and then they are automatically
removed no further action is necessary
that becomes a a vacant seat
representative
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner uh I believe I heard you
say that your department had requested
this legislation is that correct that is
correct and I would point out again
Madam chair that that's not explained in
the analysis that's been a pet Bugaboo
of my history
no problem or some Goldie you had a
question thank you madam chair I just
wanted to I have the statute in front of
me and it states two unexcused absences
so that's even better better thank you
representative okay
yes representative gold
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question commissioner
um I've gotten no complaints from any
Farmers about this bill are you aware of
any opposition from the farm community
to this bill no none whatsoever and and
I should have stated that the
the agricultural Advisory Board is in in
full support of the bill as amended by
the Senate
excellent all right other questions the
representative Bailey thank you madam
chair
could could you explain to me why we
would you would be asking the
commissioner to leave the meeting well
if you that was actually my suggestion
because if you paid any attention to the
uh my re my confirmation process and I
hope you didn't
um but
you you would have realized what a mean
bully I am and that I intimidate
everyone everywhere I go
and so it seemed that the only way to
address that would be if somebody came
in and didn't want to speak in front of
me or future Commissioners
that they'd be allowed to ask for the
commissioner to excuse him him or
herself I think that is reasonable to
give people the ability to freely speak
their thoughts without having a bully
such as myself
glaring at them
thank you thank you commissioner that
that explanation makes perfect sense
are there any uh other questions
all right seeing them thank you for your
testimony thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 146.
all right seeing none I will close
the hearing
okay representative groda has a motion
um I move auto pass on House Bill 146.
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
um I think that
um when
I I just think feels like it's a common
sense thing to do and
that's always encouraging okay thank you
representative Gould do you wish to
speak to your second yes I agree with
everything that my colleague just stated
and also
um I do get calls frequently from
especially
um The Farm Bureau and and other members
from the farm community when they're
concerned about a bill and there's been
no concerns about this one so excellent
all right anyone else
okay
not seeing any other comments the clerk
the motion is ought to pass by
representative Baroda and the clerk can
call the roll
and represent Davis was in the room when
we followed the question he was
fairly but in
representative Simon yes
representative Bailey
yes representative Santo sazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard
yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis
yes you were
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
and we should have
16 yay zero and a
lower the motion passes 16-0 and the
objections to consent
not seeing any representative groda
very or soon please
all right
I'd like to open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 208 call Senator chandley
and apologize but house rules require us
to either vote either have a scheduled
exact session or do it immediately so I
wanted to do it immediately
certainly no apology necessary I
understand this time of year too is also
so busy good morning Madam chair members
of the committee my name is Shannon
chandley and I have the privilege of
representing in the Senate
um District 11 the towns of Merrimack
Amherst Milford and Wilton I come before
you today to introduce what I hope is
one of the more simple bills that you
will see this year it is a important
bipartisan bill that um
comes to you from the Senate with a
great recommendation of
ought to pass
transparency is essential to trust in
government over the course of the
covid-19 pandemic the state receives
significant funds from the federal
government
and we're grateful to the federal
delegation for securing the needed
dollars and to the state for dispersing
them
one thing that remains to be seen is a
detailed clear accounting of the funds
that have been received from the federal
government through various recent
actions
um
as the governor noted in his budget
address one of the greatest
responsibilities we have is to be good
stewards for the taxpayer and ultimately
any funding that we receive from the
federal government came from the
taxpayers and those same taxpayers
deserve transparency and clarity about
where those dollars go
uh currently the data that is reported
and shared publicly is very limited in
scope and uh with little detailed
information it's very dense
um and uh you know for example the
current
um current reports speak to the funds
that have been accepted and to what
programs they uh go but not exactly what
has been spent or who to whom the then
uh the who the vendors are
um So to that end I bring before you SB
208 208 requires the commissioner of the
Department of administrative services
and the governor's office for emergency
relief and Recovery otherwise known as
gopher to separately report on the
disbursement of federal funds beginning
in July of 2023 the department will
those both of those departments will
create and make available on their
public websites reports of all federal
relief relief funds disbursed within 30
days of each disbursement it should be
in check register format and include the
amount date person or other entity to
whom the disbursement was made as well
as the accounting unit and class code of
the disbursement the title and number of
the expense account and a brief
description of each disbursement
um
I think that we are all well aware that
uh folks are grateful for the money that
has come in and they're glad that it is
being spent but I know that all of us
wants to understand uh well where it is
going
um I think that we also agree that
transparency and accountability and the
spending of taxpayer dollars is
supremely important and you know I I ask
your committee to um
also look favorably favorably upon this
bill and pass it and I'm happy to take
questions thank you
thank you Senator I have a question is
go for a continuing committee or just a
a covid emergency it is continuing if it
is continuing interesting I'm not sure
that it has been meeting regularly but
it does still exist and they still have
their website
thank you uh the questions
representative your heart thank you
madam chair what is the violation of not
fulfilling oh that's a great question
thank you so much for asking
um because the bill itself refers to
um the right to know Ombudsman and I
think that is so what we're trying to do
here is really make this public make it
well known and for people to also we the
fact that we have this Ombudsman Now is
really important and I think this
putting that in the bill here allows
people to know that if they have a
grievance they go to the Ombudsman and
um the Ombudsman should work to resolve
that complaint and um I think that's an
important uh it is important for our
state that we have that person in that
position uh that will oversee this or
not necessarily oversee it but respond
to any complaint all right follow up
follow up so the Ombudsman right now if
I was to actually Ombudsman for this
information Nation I would not be able
to get it
yes you wouldn't it doesn't
right now we don't necessarily have it
in this format now so just formatting I
got you thank you okay yes
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my questions Senator
um so if I understand correctly gopher
is currently making reports but
um
the dos the department of administrative
Services is not oh yeah they have
reports yes okay but it doesn't specify
vendors
not for these federal funds it doesn't I
believe it's just a general we spend so
much at this vendor it doesn't say this
was from federal funds ah okay
distinction okay thank you thank you yes
I've looked at the checkbook and it is
incredibly dense
other questions
all right
thank you very much Senator thank you
very much for your time
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate Bill 208
all right then I'll close the public
hearing
okay does someone have a motion on this
bill I'll make a motion um Madam chair
of OTP and House Bill 208 is there a
second Senate Bill 208
okay second is by representative Simon
versus Broder do you wish to speak on
your motion yes thank you I think it's
important to provide transparency when
it comes to
um this these funding sources and having
it available from two um two different
offices I think is helpful for that
transparency and for the public
uh no I think she said it quite well
okay
other uh comments questions concerns
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass and the clerk can call the
roll
representative Simon yes representative
Bailey
yes representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes yes clerk
both yes representative groda yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
and the chair yes 16 yay zero nay all
right the motion passes 16 to zero is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put it on
consent and we are in recess until 1pm
107 which is
thank you
okay
I just I don't know you got to give me a
good benefit unless you have something
thank you
tonight
but
It's One o'clock And I would like to
open the public hearing on sb49 and
welcome Senator Lang welcome Senator
length
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members
um before you is Senate Bill 49 I'm by
the way I'm Senator Tim Lang uh uh uh
senator for District Two having served
three terms in this August body over
here I finally made it over to the
Senate where they tell me the adults
live I'm still waiting to see that but
that's okay
um so Senate Bill 49's in front of you
um this bill came out of a study
committee that your chairman and I were
on along with Senator Carson to look at
the oplc and the way they deal with
things
um the reason for this bill is that each
year
oplc through collecting fees and
licenses end up turning over lapses in
Revenue after taking care of their
expenses to
um the general fund and if you
understand I'm sure this board does the
oplc that that 125 percent rule that the
cost of a license shouldn't exceed 125
of the cost to administer the license
otherwise it's considered the tax the
problem is we're taxing because we have
monies left over that we just throw to
the general fund and use for other
purposes other than for the licensees
and the boards so the purpose of this
bill is to fix that problem
um sorry I'm looking through my notes
here somewhere I have the amount of
money here it is each year the oplc in
2019 they've they lapse 3.4 million
dollars to the general fund at and again
that's from fees and license costs that
they've collected from from people
working in the uh in this in their
Industries and then it wasn't used for
those people it was used to supplement
the uh the federal the state government
so in 2019 we lapsed 3.4 million 2020 we
elapsed 3.3 million in two in 2021
relapsed 4.1 million and in 22 it's
estimated we're going to lapse about 2.6
million so what this bill does is
creates a non-lapsing fund
and instead of the these monies being
lapse of the general fund for general
purposes will be lapsed back to a
non-lapsing fund under the uh oplc for
them to be able to use it in the future
years for either Capital expenditures so
again if they need to say we'll use the
example of replace the computer system
within oplc they would have a fund to
draw from from that so it didn't come
from General funds and it was paid for
by the licensees the people who are
paying to run the oplc
um so it wouldn't come from General
general fund costs and it would be used
to benefit the licensees it could also
be used for the the oplc could use it to
lower license costs in a future year if
they had a large lapse they can turn
money back to a board and say reset your
licensing fees we or give we're granting
you basically five hundred thousand
dollars adjust your licensing fees down
you know so you don't have to raise an
extra five hundred thousand dollars but
they would be able to use this fund to
be able to draw for both uh reducing
future license costs from the people
that are paying it or to use it for
Capital expenditures there was an
amendment in the Senate put in to create
a reporting requirement I will say I'm
sure again this committee knows it does
it deals with oplc bills on a regular
basis
that oplc has changed and the lapse will
now happen by Emily by annually instead
of uh annually so once every two years
they'll submit a lump sum back they'll
hold the monies and then return it back
at the end of the year and that's what
go into fund so we require the Senate
Edna added a provision of reporting
requirement to let us know where a what
they did with the funds so if they moved
if they used it for reducing license or
costs taking a draw from the fund they
would note that if they use it for a
capital expenditure I know there's a big
push right now for software over there
to clean up the licensing process and to
allow our citizens a better way of
submitting paperwork so
happy to answer any questions but that's
it it's just a non-dedicated fund that
people who pay the fee will get the
benefit of the funds that they paid
any questions for the senator
seeing none thank you senator
representative McGuire
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol McGuire from
Merrimack 27 and I'm co-sponsor of this
bill which Senator Lang explained
and I I'm going to bring you as as soon
as I'm free to go upstairs and get the
copies
an amendment to change the first section
of it to the language that the house
Ways and Means Committee put into house
bill 445 which is on the same topic this
was a case of a study committee where
they said we need a bill on
a dedicated fund and both the senator
and a House member
went up and did it so we had two bills
on the same topic
so my plan is to take the language the
house Ways and Means worked out on House
Bill 445
put it into the Senate bill which has
the reporting requirement that is not in
and send
it to Ways and Means again to look at
that section and then return it to the
Senate uh I've discussed this with
Senator pearl of Senate Edna and he
thinks that's the best way to handle it
because by the time he has to deal with
the changes we make it will be we'll
know what's happening in Senate Bill 655
and House Bill 2 and a few other
uh areas that might affect it so we will
be able to
get the final language correct
so that's my plan I think
one reason that I'm in strong support of
this is that the license fees are fees
and therefore they should be used only
to for to provide benefits to the people
who pay the fees by allowing significant
amount of money to lapse to the general
fund
we're creating it attacks and it is an
unconstitutional tax because it is
not evenly distributed is not
proportional some of the license fees
are much higher than the other and
there's no reason why the license fees
should support the manufactured housing
board for example or be lapsed to the
general fund
for a general administration of the
state there to cover the cost of issuing
the licenses the cost of discipline and
investigations
and the other actions of the oplc
and so I hope that we should be able to
create a debt by creating a dedicated
fund
we will be able to lower license fees to
only what is necessary
and I'll answer questions if I can
thank you representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here today representative
um so is it not also the case that that
keeping the funds in the oplc's
budget will enable them to administer
their uh their boards and more
effectively because it's not a steady
state of costs it's go the costs go up
and down depending on what happens yes
that's true thank you
any other questions
uh yes representative Brian
thank you Mr chairman um Madam chair
um one of the things the senator uh
testified to that money can be reapplied
back to lower the licensing fee fees
admirable but those of us that have
worked on Municipal budgets I don't
think anybody wants to see a budget end
up like a roller coaster
you know so when you charge a fee isn't
it better to keep it level funded at
that particular rate and try to find out
maybe a worth more better worthwhile
cause it is an Overstock of money uh
that's one reason why the fees are so
resistant to change but there are boards
that consistently
over fund themselves the board of
accountancy for example
they don't have too many complaints the
board of midwives on the other hand has
a relatively high percentage of
complaints so they're somewhat
underfunded the Board of barbering I
understand has chosen to keep its fees
very low and therefore does not fully
cover its costs
so there's got to be some adjustments
because some boards pay too much and
some pay too little and if it turned out
there's more of the former than the
latter than you know
it may be a change but I'm sure they
will not object if their fees go down as
long as they stay down for a while
any other questions
thank you representative all right I
will bring bring back that amount
representative almie
thank you representative elmy city of
Lebanon
um
this bill the chair chair woman just
told me that a little while ago that it
is an early bill which means it comes
back to us again afterwards unless you
kill it on and
I just wanted to include what on the
reasons for what we did in our committee
in ways and means
which um was started by representative
ulery and then we went back and forth on
it and came up with the cap of three
million dollars on the amount that oplc
could on use could keep at the end of
the biennium
what they told us was that the capital
expenses would include the software
and possibly saving up for a new
building
um reps and rollery in particular was
and the committee were feeling that
decisions on a new building depend
should be made more by Das
on in and figuring out whether perhaps
they could be fit into the same building
with the AG's office or something like
that on
and
they told she also told us that they are
negotiating with a firm for the new
software which is probably going to be
based on an annual subscription which is
the way most software is going these
days rather than on rather than buying
outright and three million dollars is
about as much as they thought it might
cost if they had to buy it outright
for during a biennium during the
beginning of a biennium actually because
they would have more money
later in the biennium that they would
have saved up unless they get the fees
down
um
I do know several people that uh
in Realtors and and other uh professions
that feel like their fees are too high
and
and would be quite willing to see them
go down a bit again
but
lplc is still very much a work in
progress
it's been making progress which is a lot
better than where we were a few years
ago
but it's a work in progress and we don't
know where all of these bits and pieces
are likely to end up including the one
earlier today
and
um
I did also want to
so so we recommended uh
and that was passed by the house on the
consent calendar two weeks ago and we
recommended a three million dollar cap
on
uh how much they could retain
and in the next couple of years figuring
out how much
on they really do need in getting that
on an even Keel would allow taking off
that cap
I think if necessary
but
um
the other part on the new bill the one
from Senate on
from an amendment in the Senate with the
biennial fund report
I do feel that
the PLC is already producing an annual
report
and
they are also providing a financial
report to the dedicated funds compendium
that comes out every year
and
this could be very useful but I think
that it needs more detail
and I was talking to the chair about
this
after uh she called lunch
and she said that well you can do that
in ways and means you take care of
dedicated funds
and I guess
we could but if you have any good ideas
about what kinds of things we would want
in such a report that would not be
duplicative of the two that already
exist I think that would be helpful
or maybe decide that they are going to
be duplicative and we don't need this
but
thank you
thank you representative
um questions representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
is it uh I realize you're not on the
finance committee but the oplc budget
would still be under the the uh the
governor's purview with regard to the
budget it would not be their money to do
with as they see fit over and above
their operating costs isn't that correct
it would their oversight would be
budgetary controlled by the house yes we
actually were unsure when we discussed
this in committee as to whether they
would be required to go through the
building uh
and Public Works sections anyway
okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
thank you representative thank you
executive director Courtney
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Lindsay
Courtney executive director of plc
here to testify in support of Senate
Bill 49 and I wish to thank Center Lang
for bringing this forward
as mentioned this is very similar to
another bill this committee heard that
was sponsored by representative ulery so
I don't want to repeat all of the
comments that you heard earlier today as
well as in my testimony before you uh
for that bill but I just want to
highlight briefly how we got here which
is that
um the boards had all previously had
their own statutory authority to set
fees about half of those fees were
actually statutory which created kind of
an issue in terms of inconsistent
Revenue some boards because of their
statutory fees we're bringing in way
more Revenue than when compared with
their expenditures some other boards
we're not bringing in enough
at some point in 2015 oplc was granted
statutory authority to set fees but
because of statutory conflicts we have
not been able to make any changes and
um I think as of right now are finally
in a position to be able to respond to
um those necessary changes so
what we plan on doing is on July 1
instituting a new allocation method that
would allow us to better track staff
time
the the cute the significant portion of
our operating expenses are for personnel
or Personnel related costs so we we do
plan to do that for a certain period of
time in order to capture really oplc's
full expenditures and the allocation to
different boards we would need to wait a
full biennium but we believe that some
modifications might need to be made
earlier than waiting a full biennium so
we will likely make adjustments sometime
in the fall or propose adjustments based
on our review with that data and I think
um I think what that is going to do is
hopefully level set our Revenue stream
and our fees as representative McGuire
mentioned
some words are paying significantly more
than they should and it's an
unconstitution unconstitutional tax and
some boards are not covering their
expenses at all and then they need to do
that so there so we do plan on making
those changes in in the future
um but really what this bill would do is
make sure that we are not our licensee
dollars are being utilized for licensing
purposes
and that's a position that we obviously
fully support there are two Capital
expenditures that representative almi
mentioned that we testified
regarding um before Ways and Means
um on the house bill
and the first has to do with software uh
oplc has always had funding but we've
not been re we have not been fully
resourced in the sense that we have not
had sufficient in my opinion
Appropriations since its Inception in
order to do the job that we need to do
and serve our constituents so we are
starting to make those expenditures and
really put licensee dollars back into
supporting licensees which has
significantly positively impacted
Workforce
um so there are two Capital expenditures
that we would likely need to have money
in the bank for so to speak and the
first is software improvements because
as we
um are encountering Workforce challenges
throughout the state the oplc is also
encountering those problems and so we'd
like to leverage technology and maybe
reduce our
um our Reliance on
um a sizable Personnel
um as we move forward and the second
which I wasn't prepared to address today
but I will briefly mention is for
purposes of a building
um many of you may recall but we were
forced to relocate from Phil Brook which
was a state-owned building we paid
approximately two hundred thousand
dollars a year for that lease to das
and we're forced to lease a space in
about a period of 30 days and we are now
paying
um about eight hundred thousand dollars
a year
and that's a significant sum of money
that our licensees are now forced to pay
and they're
we would love to go into a state-owned
space but my concern if there were such
a space is that because we are
self-funded when things are going well
in the state we would we would go into a
state-owned space and then when other
General funded agencies need our space
we would be kicked back out again
and I have to say that the move the
transition from Phil Brook to seven
Eagle Square although I love the space
um it really impacted agency operations
and we'd like to not have to do that
we're not at a point to be able to make
an a
suggestions or asks of the legislature
but there are other state agencies
including the Lottery Commission that
have taken a different approach and we
are exploring that but that's kind of in
the future
so in any event happy to answer any
questions we think this is a reasonable
approach and are happy to comply with
any sort of reporting obligations the
legislature would like us to do
um and and we'll get the funding squared
away in the next couple of years
thank you yes representative goalie
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
first I'll say um
shocked to hear how much we're paying a
year for a building because
sitting on the study committee this
summer when the discussion was about
the leasing of the space a lot of the
trades folks looked at me and said for
that price they could have built one
hell of a building
yeah that's our opinion too but not in
30 days so uh we don't want to be paying
that much for space which is why we're
we're trying to be proactive at looking
at What other state agencies have done
the Lottery Commission was able to seek
statutory Authority and they were able
to purchase a building for three million
dollars
um that was a different Market a few
years ago but I think that the state
could make an investment and we could
you know eliminate that
um that line item and represented cost
savings my concern with that is without
the statutory authority to allow oplc or
the boards or however we do it to be
able to purchase a building it would
have to be under deaths and then as soon
as another state agency that's General
funded actually needs the space because
they're General funded we would be
forced to relocate again and I think
that's why we've seen other self-funded
agencies move into lease space or
procure their own space outside of that
solution
although question
when I look at
the amendment that's in front of us and
it goes the same with the bill
that money's in the fund in excess of
three million so at the end of each Bion
and be transferred to the general fund
shouldn't we be stating instead of
transferring to the general fund that
it shall be used to reassess fees and be
used specifically for fees and not back
to the general fund because we're going
to be back in that same scenario we're
in now where any
excess fees are going to the state of
New Hampshire versus back to what we are
trying to do is reduce costs for
licensees
yeah I would agree with that I mean
we're willing to uh support a cap
because we think something is better
than nothing but I still think a cap
that has a lapse back to the general
fund further creates the same problem
that we're dealing with and we would
support rather than having money go back
to licensees because that may be
difficult to do having the money be
utilized
uh in the future biennium to have a you
know a reduction in licensing fees in
the future that may be the easier
easiest approach as opposed to issuing
refunds because there's a cost
associated with that
and would you be work
any other questions yes representative
Gerard
thank you chair
how how many employees are you looking
how many people do you need to have in
office space
well right now the large majority of our
staff are in the office uh the only ones
that are not in the office are our
inspectors that work remotely
um
I think some of our staff could probably
work remotely but we are still a young
agency we are still developing policies
and procedures we're still establishing
internal controls so I am not
comfortable with sending a sizable
portion of our stat staff off site at
the moment right now we have 126
authorized positions and I don't
anticipate a need for a significant
increase beyond that in fact I think as
we continue to leverage technology I
think we could see a reduction
um
in in the number of necessary staff
positions through attrition of course
thank you follow so how many people are
going to the office how many people
right now are in the office 120 ish
physical yes all right thank you
thank you
um I do have a question as well
and I don't know if you can answer this
really off the top of your head or not
but
um the boards are able to collect these
in 125 of the covering their own costs
if all of the boards were to collect 125
percent of their operating costs what
would the excess be so we've got a three
million dollar cap what can that look
like
presently right so if our budget is
14 million dollars assuming that you
know what's 25 above that another three
to four million dollars ish um
but I will say it's not easy to project
Revenue at oplc because of the shifts in
the market
um so for example when things are going
well we see a huge flux in the number of
real estate licensee applications or
during the pandemic we saw a significant
number of Health Care Workforce
Healthcare applications so I think three
million dollars is reasonable just to
have as a buffer
we start off the biennium with no money
no money and
um July August September are not huge
months for renewals so we are often in
the red and thankfully we can pay
Personnel costs when we don't have any
any funny uh funding
um but I think that we're unique in that
sense that we don't have any sort of
buffer and
um and it's it's
often trying to play a game of catch-up
you know December and June or are
um highest months in terms of uh Revenue
because of our renewal cycles and so
it's just not clear from year to year
how much revenue we're going to bring in
right so when a board exceeds the 125
percent what's the protocol for
addressing that because it sounds like
it kind of goes on year after year after
year without really being appropriately
addressed yeah so historically it hasn't
been addressed because either the fees
were set in statute and we would need to
seek a statutory change
or because there was a conflict as to
who had the authority to set fees and I
think that conflict this session has
largely been resolved hopefully
um
but uh but that has been the issue
any other questions
thank you director
thank you for your time
Stephen raincort
sorry Steven ringcourt
good afternoon committee and committee
chairman thank you my name is Stephen
Rancourt I'm a licensed electrician
under the oplc and also the executive
director of the ecba
um we originally were very much involved
with the study commission that
representative Willie is talking about
and
um we've been paying 125 and over the
course of the years of doing this we we
were on our own
um just under the governor like all
these other boards we moved to the
Department of Safety when we did and we
were told it's going to get better and
administratively and they were going to
help us and then our money got used for
the stuff that 25 became very lucrative
in essence we're cash cows because we
cover our fees plus 25 so
um we felt that the non-lapsing fund was
definitely holding back the oplc and
servicing the licensees and we we agree
that that should go forward I believe
that this warning in 445 that's supposed
to be merged according to representative
McGuire that had something about the cap
originally we wanted the cap because as
the administration's changes and the
director and executive director over
time
we've seen abuse happen in other
situations where and it's always hoping
that protected but we would much rather
see all the money go back to us and
especially talking about a building if
they're looking to do that maybe there's
a way to specify that maybe other than
that cap the rest goes into a fund to
purchase a building because we went as
she explained from 200 000 to 800 000
and it wasn't any fault of the executive
director it was just how it happened so
we're now going to pay I believe it's
10-year lease so we're going to pay
eight million dollars in rent for the
next 10 years now I don't know if
Lindsay can let you know how long what
confirm the lease is 10 years and what
we would have to do to get out of it and
maybe instead of putting a cap on it put
something in there that dedicates the
difference towards that building that
would be prudent and it's a good thing
to do
because we don't need a building
downtown here one is terrible parking
you can't get in there you gotta get
paid or Park everywhere it's just so
some building off site will be much
better
if we can put those funds towards it
that would be you know be a smart thing
to do and take the difference of that
cap you just don't want that cap getting
abused
and then some of the things that I know
that they've been fighting and I hope
that if this goes through will change we
had put in our budget years before when
we moved that every year we purchased a
new car for our inspectors we had four
inspectors
after so each car would end up being
four years old a couple hundred thousand
miles on it starting to cost more than
do it
now we're getting hand-me-downs to the
mechanical board that just moved in
there I don't know what happened to our
cars I know that the budget's been
constricted with everything that she's
trying to do so we hope that this would
help fix this and give our inspector
some dedicated spaces in the office
himself I know they're supposed to be on
the field but they still need a place to
land to write out reports take care of
things and stuff and so
we're cautious as to letting the you
know whether we need the cap or what's
going to happen with it is it going to
go back to us I don't think I don't
think personally sending refunds is good
I think decreasing the fees going
forward if it if the money was there
would be the best thing to do as well
but so providing that wording is coming
in and this committee might I know it
might but Ways and Means for the dollar
amount but maybe there's a way to
appropriate that additional money keep
it all there and put it towards
for you know looking for a new building
depending on how long that is if it's 10
years out and they put you know
five million dollars a year towards the
building or whatever it may be you know
what I mean it's maybe the committee can
come up with something so we support the
non-lapsing we're cautious about the
abuse and we hope that it does go back
to us in the way that it should to get
us back to where we were and even simple
things I think they need for licensing
you know we've mentioned before I can't
even get a license printed outright
because they have to fight with a
DOI for the state as opposed to them
having their own software to do it it's
a torture so we little things like that
would be good to get back to having so
that's all thank you any questions
thank you very much would anyone else
like to speak on this bill
not all
welcome back Senator Lane
thank you guys I just wanted to speak to
the cap that you're talking about what's
going on we did consider that over in
the Senate and the reason why we chose
not we we consciously chose not to put a
cap on here is because our goal is to
allow the director to create a 10-year
plan
and and be able to say this much money
this of this fund is is set aside for
this purpose that we know in five years
we're going to have this big number
expense of whatever that might be
whether it's a building or anything else
but the reason we specifically chose not
to and instead put a reporting
requirement is is just for that reason
we want oplc to be able to create a
long-term plan like we do in our cities
and towns our counties in our school
districts is to be able to use that fund
and and be able to earmark money and say
okay we've set aside to you know the
three million dollars we have this year
the money that was lapsing we're gonna
we're gonna set aside 500 million
dollars for a building if that's what
we're doing or whatever the long-term
capital expenditure is that in 10 years
I know we have to make and so that was
the reason why we specifically chose not
to put a cap on the bill and to instead
require reporting requirements so the
legislature knows what the heck they're
doing with the money
um that we know that they're putting
aside money because they're going to
have a major software upgrade that's
going to cost you know three million
dollars in five years in the next five
years so they're going to start setting
aside that money so it's not a one-time
hit of three million dollars zeroing out
the fund but instead be able to set
aside the money and use it just like a
savings account from the people that it
benefits to be able to take care of that
so they don't get hit with a an increase
because they had a three million of 4.5
million dollar you know overrun on on
costs and they can now use this fund off
set that not have to raise fees so that
was just to be clear that being said if
you're going to tell me you're going to
kill my bill without a cap you've got to
put the cap on it so I'll be pragmatic
and take what I can get but I just want
to make you aware the Senate did discuss
this at length about setting a cap and
the reason we didn't because we expect
the director to create a 10-year plan
and talk about big Capital expenditures
they may have coming up and be able to
create set-asides for that money so
representative Gerhard thank you chair
I'm just thinking of the previous
10-year plan with the lease on the
building
so it breaks down to six thousand six
hundred sixty six dollars per person per
year to rent that
do a lease it so would this if there was
to be no cap and there was a chunk of
chunk of change sitting in there would
the legislature have say on what occurs
with that money or they would simply go
out build a building and we see
afterwards the effects of decisions that
they make so again that would still go
through a Das process right because
there's Contracting and all kinds of
stuff that has to happen in the creation
of a new State Building so that would
still uh I don't think any of that would
change the difference is that the
funding source for that building would
change gotcha all right thank you
thank you
thank you Senator appreciate it
yes representative
this is a hell of a way to negotiate
with the Senate I was just thinking the
same thing
but on
the
what is here doesn't really explain that
and this is the first time we'd heard
that there was is it 800 000 or 900 000
a year
building that they've been forced into
um and on I don't think it makes it more
important that this biennial report on
the expenditures of the fund specifies
what it is that you're looking for
to make this thing work and I do think
part of the problem is that we're trying
to solve a long-term problem with the
short term
view of it so that if this can be much
better done in a few years after
after things have worked themselves out
thanks thank you
all right that's all I have for a
testimony on this so I will
close the public hearing on HB 49
.
give me just one sec
understand
um okay 12 hours 12 hours ago
yeah I think we'll have to change the
pickings okay
I'd like to open the public hearing on
sb107
and welcome representative McGuire
oh Grant dude Graham first
Grand Posse for Senator Carson
uh thank you Mr chair members of the
Edna committee I'm Grant bosse from the
New Hampshire Senate here to introduce
Senate Bill 107 on behalf of Senator
Sharon Carson the Bill's Prime sponsor
she had hoped to be here but asked me to
pinch hit if we didn't see her come over
the horizon
Senate Bill 107 seeks to amend RSA 332
G1 which gives guidelines for regulatory
boards and commissions that balance the
responsibility of safeguarding the
health of the public with the protection
of those who work in their fields sp107
would make sure entry into the workforce
is not barred under RSA 332 G10 boards
are prohibited from denying entry into a
profession based on a past criminal
conviction unless there is a substantial
relationship between the profession and
the past criminal conviction but under
RSA 332 G13
an individual May petition the board at
any time to determine if that person's
criminal record would disqualify that
person from obtaining State recognition
in practicing in their desired
profession SB 107 seeks to reconcile the
two different standards in these
statutes maintaining the substantial and
direct relationship between the
conviction and the occupation
sb107 would require boards to
demonstrate that denial suspension or
revocation of a license serves to
protect Public Safety the right to
petition aboard and appeal decisions are
included and it sets time frames for
boards to respond to such requests SB
107 clarifies the language of RSA 332g
in such a way that it protects Public
Safety but also ensures fairness for the
applicant creating a consistent standard
a few other provisions of the bill it
creates a carve out under RSA 332 G3 for
boards under the oplc it amends RSA 332
G8 to clarify the time frame for which a
border commission must conclude hearings
and it repeals RSA 332 G5 relative to
the right to appeal decisions before the
electrician's board SB 107 was amended
by the Senate Edna committee to include
suggested language from oplc and it
passed on the consent calendar if you
have questions specific for Senator
Carson I'll be sure she gets you an
answer otherwise I would defer to the
oplc staff here on the implementation of
the bill Senator Carson thanks you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 107. thank you
thank you very much
I think you're all set
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I didn't
don't have much to add except that it's
very important to clarify the issue of
criminal records because that can be a
barrier to entry and so this is to
make sure that someone who has a
a record that is not perfectly clear is
given due process and fair consideration
of whether that should stop them from
working and I strongly support that
section
thank you answer questions if you have
them any questions
thank you all set thank you so much
John garrigan and Douglas osterhot
thank you
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for having us my
name is Douglas osterhau I am General
counselor for oplc uh with me is John
garrigan John I'll let you introduce
yourself
I'm John garrigan I'm the chief
administrative prosecutor at oplc
I think the bill was presented very well
and uh kind of hits on the points that I
would hit on but I would just for a
little background information the reason
oplc asked to have this change made is
we've come across some sort of
conflicting language between 332 G10 and
332 G13 and so both of those
deal with criminal background checks and
how they pertain to licensure one of the
difficulties is that the standard is
actually different so under 32g10 the
criminal background check would have to
be substantially related under 332g 13
you would have to have a violent
misdemeanor or felony conviction so it
actually creates a couple of interesting
scenarios where potentially an
individual could apply under 332g13
which allows for a it's kind of a
declaratory ruling in front of the board
and you you go before the board and you
said based on my criminal background
check would this preclude me from
licensure and you could go through that
analysis you could get the green light
to go ahead for the board but because
the standards are different when it came
time to do the application itself
you could be denied that could actually
happen after you've done the course
sought permission from the board Etc the
other interesting thing that could
potentially arise and we haven't seen
this come up before but theoretically it
could happen is that an individual could
apply for licensure
and simultaneously because under 13 you
have the ability to petition the board
at any time so you could apply for
licensure have the 332 G10 standard
foreign
have that 332 G10 standard applied and
simultaneously like I said go before the
board with a 32 G13 standard which is
that violent misdemeanor felony language
and same individual same set of facts
you could potentially Come Away with a
different answer depending on which
standard we noticed this we got into a
conversation the question came before
the oplc and our attorneys as to whether
or not an application was a petition
under 332g13 and that kind of got us
down the road we were in today so our
goal with this is really just to tighten
up the language you can see we've asked
for a repeal of 332 G13 in its entirety
but we took a lot of that language and
just moved it up to 332 G10 so we stayed
with the clear and convincing standard
because we are talking about licensure
it should be difficult to deny someone
from practicing and then we kept the
substantially related language which
from 332 G10 we kept language from
332g13 as I said and so hopefully we end
up when the language is combined with
sort of The Best of Both Worlds and
we're hoping for consistent answers from
boards for licensees and just a fair
process across the board there is some
additional language in here
uh some of it's just clean up language
but I do want to point out I'm looking
at page three on the PDF line 11.
Section 5 says repeal RSA 332 G5
relative to the right to appeal final
decisions of the elect electricians
board that request was put in when
original 655 was put into before the
house and so it was part of that whole
cleanup package I just wanted to point
it out because I know the house pulled a
lot of that cleanup language out of 655
and it's something we'll probably be
addressing next legislative season but
um it might also in in line with that be
appropriate to pull it here that's a
policy decision but I did want to flag
it for the committee today happy to take
any questions
any questions from the committee
yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman so uh as you're
probably aware from your review
uh there have been complaints uh from
the public or at least advocacy on
behalf of uh a review of this whole
situation because a lot of the license
requirements in the past you talked of a
good moral character or and use words
like moral turpitude and so forth a lot
of that has been pulled out of the
statute because it was deemed to be
you know too heavy-handed but you have
situations where
people may have a criminal record
that you know involves some kind of
physical
uh misconduct and and people
would potentially be look being they
would be looking at trying to get a p an
appeal through where they want to
practice something where they would be
in contact physical contact with
clientele or so forth and that becomes a
pretty Sticky Wicket so uh
did you feel that this proposed language
is going to uh
resolve all the issues I know asking for
perfectionist
too high a standard but resolve all the
issues could you just speak to my
question and the changes that we've
already made over the last 20 years
I think this bill is going to be a
really good instrument to allow
it's going to protect applicants so that
they don't get denied licensure based
solely on a criminal record but I think
it's also going to give boards
professional boards the ability to take
a look at that and make sure that
they're not letting through say a
violent offender or somebody it's going
to give them the flexibility is that
does help uh follow up follow up so the
thing is and and these appeals would it
be handled Now by one office Mr
garrigan's office or whatever and and so
forth if so you'd have one office
handling all boards reviews as opposed
to because in the past I think it was
kind of piecemeal
I'm not sure this would solve that issue
because not all boards under 332 gr
title 30 boards or oplc boards I do
think it's a good change for the state
regardless because it's going to ensure
consistency and application or at least
it shouldn't it's a step in the right
direction okay but but again that is why
we tried to combine that substantially
related language with
with you know the 310 and 332g13
one more so but in your opinion this is
clearly a better process and that we
should be adopting this I would say even
if we don't get the perfect
I think so like I said we did try in
drafting the language and proposing it
bringing forward we tried to capture the
best of both statutes okay thank you
very much
any other questions yes representative
Cooley
thank you Mr chair
and the final determinations are still
going to be left up
to the board or your office correct the
board
follow up and going back uh uh to the
final page on these repeals
uh line 13 repealing G13 relative to the
right to petition a board for review and
criminal record is repealed that go over
that one more time as to that repeal
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
go over that repeal one more time on G13
yeah so 332 G13 was that's the title of
this section the right to petition the
board and that lets you petition the
board at any time to see if your
criminal background check would preclude
you from licensure but that could come
before the application process but again
that standard was different it was
relying solely on the felony or violent
misdemeanor language so what we did was
we actually took a lot of that language
from G13 I don't have both bills and are
both in front of me but if you look at
the language of SP 107 you would see
that a lot of that language verbatim
from 13 was just moved up into 10 to put
it all in one space
thank you
any other questions
yes representative Schmidt so it just
occurred to me how much how much of this
appeal stuff is there out there among
all the boards I mean is it uh we're
dealing with a lot of appeals or is it
just a question of however many we have
we should be handling it better than we
do I would say the second I couldn't
give you an answer because this is for
licensure application right purposes I
wouldn't have a number off the top of my
head how many cases looking up in this
we have seen them now and it came up
last summer
thank you gentlemen
thank you very much
Stephen Rancourt
foreign
good afternoon committee my name is
Steven reincourt licensed electrician
State of New Hampshire and representing
the ecba we just had a couple of
comments less concerns on page one line
three we just want to make sure and
clarify that they're using State
recognition throughout the document but
that's just for this bill so they can
refer to those and it's not changing
what those are because that would have a
much bigger impact so if the committee
can make sure that that's all it is
which I believe and then if um if the
oplc is going to uh recommendation is to
move section 332 G5 we obviously had a
concern with that were you okay with the
bill if they removed that if not we had
some proposed amendment that we'd like
to submit to the board if they're going
to consider keeping it to add some
additional warning that has to do with
our appeal to the State Building Code
board for applicable and in uh codes so
if they're going to remove it if not I
had some testimony to hand out it's
totally up to the committee if you want
it or what they're why don't you hand it
out
feeling is
other than those two concerns as uh Doug
mentioned you know sometimes you can
have somebody come in and apply do the
pre pre-approval thing to make sure they
fit the qualifications and there was
some confusion at the end you really
don't want somebody going through four
years of schooling and work and find out
they can't do it after they were told
they were so we we think that the bill
fixes a lot of that and we're okay with
that it was just those two issues so
great
any questions
thank you
thank you very much thanks
is there anybody else who would like to
testify on SB 107
if not I will close the public hearing
we're all Carol we're all set
I was here I don't know where you were I
was in this chair
but the um schedule says we were
supposed to meet at 1 30 for this bill
in the morning A.M
um that's something we should discuss
and I think the exactly all right
all right there's a couple of issues
that we might need to discuss with this
so I'm going to
make a motion of ought to pass
is there a second
I'll second okay
um
there are some concerns that we ought to
discuss before we vote so representative
[Music]
well we we were discussing that uh
there were concerns about uh what was
put forward by the electrician's board
and
um I think given a little time perhaps
they can work something out he I just
saw them discussing with with the legal
counsel
um
yes
representative Gould did I misunderstand
I thought that the concern was about
something that's that's going to be
removed
yes
and then the other concern was State
recognition which I obviously that that
term caught my ear that's the
who as I recall the testimony he was
saying that's used in this
in this bill to mean or the section to
mean essentially license or
certification or registration or
whatever
instead of saying
license certification registration it
says recognition so if that's just a a
replacement word kind of thing or an
alternate word and the other sections
being removed is there any further well
the question is should that
are
should 332 G5 be removed
because it allows an appeal to the State
Building Code review board
in the cases where the question is the
interpretation of the of the building
code
and so that's a that's a question
representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie thank you
madam chair if you wave I think you want
to talk
yeah and
I look at the repeal that we hear from
Mr raincoat that he would like to see
that repeal removed from this
is what I was hearing correct
no it's it's our statute not theirs
sorry Steve Ryan court again um if the
oplc is willing to remove that repeal
because we would lose the ability to
appeal to the state building code for
either fire or building codes for
interpretation and application you don't
have to go to Supreme Court because I
understand a certain code a certain way
and we might not disagree with the board
that's all so we don't want to lose that
ability and if you repeal that we would
how if I may ask how often does this
come up is this a couple of cases a year
I would say probably something I've
known probably four or five over for as
long as it's been in there it's not um
I don't think it's something that's
abused so to speak it but when you have
a code issue we had like one time we had
one inspector decided a structure was
going to be considered something else so
it went to the whole torturous process
to determine that and whether or not we
could put generator switches on it so
it's stuff like that okay sorry
follow up yes please
so I guess my concern seeing we're in a
discussion well my concern is hearing
that explanation and it
has a reasoning to be kept in statute
that I would ask that we hold off and
have an amendment to re take the repeal
out
before we go forward all right that
makes sense representative Schmidt well
you're now we're going in the direction
I was wondering because I presume that
this issue did not come up in the Senate
um
I don't recall to be honest with you
there's been so many bills this year
House Bill 655 had a house bill too had
some of it I don't remember if it came
up in the Senate no because I mean the
two attorneys from oplc have now left
the room so we we can't bounce it off of
them
might well have
uh
like I said there's so many pieces
floating around this year I mean my
question about the Senate is obviously
if it if it came up and the Senate
turned it down that would be significant
but but the point is that now that the
issue has been raised uh I think I think
we have to have the oplc attorneys look
at this and decide whether how they want
to proceed so I'm in favor of
Representative Goldie's suggestion to
okay pull it back at the moment fair
enough I representative Simon thank you
yeah I would add that the
um
members from oplc the lawyers
took special pains to point that out to
us they wanted to make sure that we knew
that it was there so they obviously
assumed that it might be an issue that
we should look at
yeah
thank you I also make him make a motion
I mean also would like you to pull it
back because this also overlaps a little
bit with the what we're trying to do
with health bill 655.
so I think that this is something that
we can address with
with everyone as a
as opposed to specific all right well
the
um
that's fine so we will recess and
to the next scheduled executive session
which will be which will not be next
week
so it'll be at least two weeks uh before
we do before I
this is not an early bill so there's no
problem with it we've got all of April
if I may Madam chair also we did submit
the same wording to uh the senate for
Hospital 655 once we realized that was
in there as well pretty much the same
thing it says we can only appeal to the
state to the Supreme Court we added
except as 674-34 allows so we're trying
to keep it consistent if it's all for us
okay well we will
comes will consider what's being done in
the sen in the Senate on 655 before we
make any decisions on this
all right in that case we are done there
is no committee tomorrow but uh there is
session starting at nine so I'll see you
all there